[Musica]
Non so se nel paradiso ci sia bisogno di
sapere dove ci si trovi ma sulla terra
adesso sì ed è vero da tanto
tempo adesso noi ce l'abbiamo un sistema
comodo per tutti
il navigatore nel cellulare
accurato ma un tempo sapere dove ci si
trovi era un il problema enorme andare
per mare faceva
paura perché i marinai in assenza di
riferimenti non sapevano dov'erano e
dove stavano andando si dice che la
Magna Grecia cioè l'espansione dei Greci
nel sud Italia si aduto all'Etna L'Etna
è un faro naturale visibile da
grandissima distanza e quindi questi
loro viaggi frequenti i marinai
sentivano
confortati sapendo che a un certo punto
quel Faro sarebbe apparso per
guidarli Per secoli il problema di
sapere dove sono è stato chiamato il
problema della longitudine
e Sì perché per un marinaio nel mare
aperto sapere la sua latitudine Se
questa è la terra in quale parallelo mi
trovo sono un grado e un primo sopra
L'equatore sono poco
sotto il tropico sono nel parallelo di
Gibilterra era relativamente semplice
basta guardare l'altezza massima che nel
giorno raggiunge il sole Qualcuno
potrebbe dire Beh se stai a nord Basta
guardare l'altezza della stella polare
vero ma solo nei secoli recenti perché
all'epoca della Mag Grecia per la
precisione degli equinozi l'asse della
terra puntava un punto del cielo dove
non c'era una stella di riferimento non
c'era la stella polare la stella volare
del tempo
per la longitudine è molto più difficile
per la longitudine Ho bisogno di un
orologio un orologio che tenga il tempo
nel porto da cui sono partito e segua il
tempo battendolo per tutta la
naazione e quindi se mi trovo poi in
mezzo al mare posso Calcolando il
e io la longitudine del Porto la
conosco voi come lo chiamate il
navigatore che c'è qua dentro lo
chiamate il GPS c'è qualcuno che
comincia a chiamarlo
Galileo Beh ci sono quattro sistemi al
mondo che alimentano tutti i navigatori
sono il GPS quell' americano è il primo
c'è il russo glonass c'è il cinese
baidou e poi c'è Galileo che è il
sistema dell'Unione Europea e Galileo Il
Galileo è il sistema con le di gran
lunga con le migliori prestazioni ed è
anche ormai diffusa ci sono dai tre ai 4
miliardi di ricevitori Galilei in questo
momento in uso e Galileo si chiama così
perché Galileo Galilei Il nostro è stato
il solutore del problema della
longitudine e questo comincia da una
notte fondamentale della storia della
scienza l'11 di gennaio del
1610 qui vicino a Padova Galileo Punta
il cannocchiale verso Giove e capisce
una cosa che l'umanità non conosceva non
sapeva vede che quello è un pianeta in
cui orbitano dei satelliti intorno la
prima notte ne vede tre la seconda
scopre anche il quarto quelli che adesso
chiamiamo io Ganimede Europa e
Callisto Ma siccome Galileo era un genio
assoluto capisce che è quello e anche
l'orologio preciso di cui l'umanità ha
bisogno per sapere dove si trova perché
le orbite dei satelliti sono
estremamente regolari e sono anche
complesse con quattro e quindi facendo
delle tavole di previsioni
puoi riconoscere con un'osservazione
attenta delle posizioni del satelliti
Che ora
è e siccome Galileo è anche un artigiano
ed era un artigiano per arrotondare lo
stipendio di di professore ha ideato
anche il celatone il celatone è un casco
con un cannocchiale
incernierato che aiuta il marinaio a
tenere nell'angolo di vista del
cannocchiale Giove mentre la barca Rolla
e beccheggia Beh direi che possiamo ben
ragione dire che Galileo è il della
prima App di navigazione satellitare del
mondo ma torniamo ai nostri comodi
tempi
questo questo che è così comodo che mi
permette di sapere dove sono più o meno
con un metro se ci fosse in una mappa
questo tappeto rosso forse mi potrebbe
anche localizzare qua questo che mi dice
in un deto di strade beh prendi quel
viicolo lì devi andare
Ma come funziona e perché la chiamo
Navigazione
satellitare Che c'entra lo
spazio da bambini Avete mai fatto il
gioco del
fulmine c'è un temporale a un certo
punto vedo un lampo in quella direzione
tengo la direzione e comincio comincio
immediatamente a contare con la cadenza
dei secondi
1 2
3 4 5 6 e poi il tuono e allora posso
fare il punto posso fare il punto perché
so che il fulmine è caduto in quella
direzione a 2 km di distanza poi possono
Uh guarda vicino a casa di nonno
Beh perché dico 2 km perché il suono
viaggia a 350 m al secondo e in 6
secondi percorre 2 km quindi ho
trasformato una misura di tempo una
misura di propagazione di tempo in una
distanza bene la navigazione satellitare
quella che usiamo tutti i giorni
funziona con lo stesso
principio ed è basato su dei satelliti
che orbitano intorno alla terra che
hanno due caratteristiche specialissime
La prima è che hanno degli orologi
dentro di estrema accuratezza estrema la
seconda che conoscono con accuratezza la
posizione in cui sono e mandano un
messaggio molto
semplice sono il satellite X questa è la
mia posizione e questo è l'istante in
cui mando questo
segnale e allora il ricevitore che è qui
si può calcolare quanto ci ha messo il
segnale elettromagnetico del satellite a
arrivare fino a me che tengo in mano il
cellulare e sapendo che la luce con cui
si provoc il segnale elettromagnetico va
300.000 km al secondo mi calcolo la
distanza improvvisamente so io che sono
qua so quanto disto da quel satellite
lontanissimo nello spazio
geometricamente è come se potessi dire
So di stare il punto in cui sto è sulla
superficie di una sfera di cui so il
centro perché il centro è quella
posizione così accurata del satellite e
Sol è come il raggio Alla distanza che
ho misurato in questo modo bene maora lo
posso fare contemporaneamente con un
altro
satellite stesso procedimento il
satellite manda il messaggio lo ricevo e
posso costruire idealmente un'altra
sfera in questa sfera che è localizzata
il centro è il secondo satellite e so
che io sono il punto sono deve essere
per forza sulla superficie della sfera
che ha come raggio la distanza fra me e
questo secondo satellite Ma allora devo
stare
nell'intersezione perché sto sulla
superficie la sfera quindi la prima
sfera l'intersezione con la seconda
sfera vedete il secondo satellite era
più
lontano l'intersezione fra due le
superfici due sfere è una
circonferenza Ma se faccio
contemporaneamente l'acquisizione di un
terzo satellite bene Ho la terza sfera e
calcolo l'intersezione fra questa terza
sfera e la circonferenza di prima sono
due punti uno è una conseguenza
matematica che non ha un significato
fisico è perso nello spazio e che posso
scartare facilmente l'altro e dove sono
io con la precisione del
metro non ho bisogno soltanto di tre
satelliti perché in
realtà io voglio che questo sistema
funzioni dappertutto in tutto il mondo e
allora ho bisogno di una costellazione e
ce ne vogliono almeno 24 possiamo dire
che Galileo aveva trovato un orologio
fatto da satelliti naturali e noi
abbiamo costruito dei satelliti
artificiali che hanno a bordo degli
orologi accuratissimi quanto sono
accurati Beh quelli di Galileo del
sistema Galileo accumulano un errore di
1 secondo ogni 10 milioni di anni
per la cronaca Galileo Galilei Il nostro
è stato il primo scienziato al mondo a
tentare un esperimento per calcolare la
velocità della luce non c'è
riuscito
Però meno di un secolo dopo un un fisico
Danese ha fatto la prima misura l'ha
fatto sulla scia di di Galileo perché lo
ha misurato dalle osservazioni delle
eclissi di io dietro Giove io er il
primo satellite scoperto da
Galileo
ora il principio è semplice però c'è una
difficoltà abbiamo detto accuratezza del
metro e la luce percorre un metro in 3
miliardesimi di secondo e avere a che
fare con i miliardesimi di secondo non è
semplice E c'è voluta buona parte della
fisica sviluppata nel XO secolo e anche
qualche
qualche sviluppo tecnologico della
seconda metà del del XO secolo per
concepire e poi
realizzare
i i sistemi di nazione
satellitare pensate di avere a che fare
qualitativamente con gli effetti della
teoria della
relatività Beh ne abbiamo a che fare
tutti i giorni quando usiamo il
cellulare per per focalizzarci se il
nostro cellulare Non facesse non tenesse
conto degli effetti della relatività nei
suoi calcoli non funzionerebbe nessuno
di noi se per caso il suo cellulare
avesse facesse delle incredibili bizze e
si rifiutasse di fare le correzioni
relativistiche e avesse impostato Piazza
garbaldi 4 Rovigo seguendo quel
cellulare non l'avreste mai più trovata
non è possibile ed è la prima volta
nella storia dell'umanità che abbiamo a
che In pratica con le conseguenze della
relatività e questo è è un caso
particolare in fisica in genere lo
sviluppo di una nuova teoria fisica e
deriva dalla necessità di spiegare un
fenomeno che una teoria precedente non
spiega la relatività no nasce da una
fantasia Una fantasia di Albert Einstein
che Immagina di seguire un raggio di
luce tiene conto l'equazione di maxel e
arriva ad una conclusione del tutto
controintuitiva e cioè che il tempo non
è assoluto il tempo rallenta il tempo
accelera a seconda di condizioni
gravitazionali o di velocità relative EB
Beh in questo conto così
straordinariamente delicato in cui devo
stabilire una distanza per il tramite
del tempo che ci ha messo la luce a
percorrerla Beh di questi effetti ne
devo tenere conto Poi ci sono anche
tante altre cose per queste accuratezze
C'è l'effetto dell'atmosfera che può
ritardare la velocità D di propagazione
in maniera imprevedibile c'è la
situazione di eccitazione del Sole tante
altre cose c'è un effetto che forse
potreste aver notato
nel
quotidianamente a me è capitato a
Venezia recentemente in una calle molto
stretta a un certo punto guard il
cellulare stavo cercando una strada
e fa delle cose assurde mi sposta in
cima a un palazzo oppure continua a
cambiare idea su dove devo andare E
allora semplicemente me lo metto in
tasca chiedo a qualcuno ma dov'è il
campo più vicino ci vado mi affretto
vado al centro del campo e aspetto un
pochettino che al navigatore gli si
schiariscono le idee e questo perché
Perché in un
vicolo il
navigatore può non vedere direttamente
il satellite potrebbe averlo ricevuto
dal riflesso degli edifici che gli sono
intorno Ma lui continua a Interpretare
quel percorso come una linea diretta e
questo gli confonde le
idee Beh ora abbiamo parlato della
Navigazione per guidarci ma in realtà è
qualcosa di molto invasivo molto che ci
aiuterà perché abiliterà delle delle
applicazioni le sta già abilitando
importanti l'agricoltura di precisione
la nostra sicurezza personale la
sicurezza delle
transazioni delle transazioni
finanziarie il monitoraggio di strutture
complesse con precisioni sub
millimetriche tutte queste sono
abilitate dalla dalla navigazione
satellitare e poi c'è l'incipiente mondo
dei veicoli
autonomi le navi I treni gli aerei i
droni i robot Insomma tutta una serie di
cose che possiamo dire tra l'altro
servono a ridurre la
fatica la navigazione satellitare Noi
l'abbiamo creata per utenti che stanno
sulla terra però se ci leviamo un po'
continua a funzionare un pochettino e se
tutto va bene l'anno prossimo un oggetto
andrà sulla luna all luner all'interno
di una sonda lunare questo oggetto è un
ricevitore Galileo
GPS che farà delle misurazioni percorso
e poi vedrà se funziona ancora un
pochettino la navigazione satellitare
sulla luna questo in attesa poi di fare
i già previsti sistemi di navigazione
satellitare intorno alla
luna E questo sarà il primo oggetto
europeo a posarsi sulla luna ed è un
oggetto che è costruito qua vicino in
Veneto a Bassano del
Grappa nella storia della umana ci sono
state tante civiltà e hanno una cosa in
comune molte molto c'è un tipo di mito
che poi è stato chiamato il mito
dell'età
dell'oro è un modo collettivo di dire
però è un mito che ha molto a che fare
con il paradiso terrestre ora ci sono
due cose comuni in questi miti dell'età
dell'oro La prima è che è un è un mondo
dove si fa poco o niente Fatica La
seconda è che è un è un'epoca irmede
perduta che non tornerà mai ma siccome
Noi stiamo facendo di tutto per
diminuire la fatica o annullarla Ma non
è che il paradiso debba ancora arrivare
e allora se ce lo chiediamo possiamo
sapere ma quanto tempo abbiamo per avere
l'esperienza del Paradiso per cercare di
fare il paradiso Beh sulla terra lo
sappiamo abbiamo un tempo lunghissimo
abbiamo a disposizione 4 miliardi di
anni certo fra 4 miliardi di anni sole
ci renderà la vita un po' difficile ma
comunque abbiamo tanto tempo ma se
questa domanda ce la chiediamo per tutto
l'universo che possiamo dire Beh
l'universo è in espansione Ma le
nebulose le galassie continuano a
esistere e si formano e sono delle
fucine di stelle e pianeti
incredibilmente longeve che andranno
avanti per molto molti molti molti
miliardi di anni e dove si formano anche
stelle che hanno della aspettative di
vita migliaia di volte maggiore di
quelle di una stella come il sole Beh
possiamo dire che l'universo come
opportunità di ospitare Il Paradiso è
solo
all'inizio
Grazie